okay Adam sent me this this is happening
on Reddit a Reddit user asked the open
AI chatbot to review Conan O'Brien needs
a friend so our show has now been
reviewed by artificial intelligence and
written a review would you like to hear
it oh God yes please okay Conan O'Brien
needs a friend is a hilarious and
heartfelt book by the late night talk
show host Conan O'Brien O'Brien opens up
about his life and career and how he has
struggled to find friends in the
entertainment industry he also discusses
his personal life including divorce and
his children
foreign
the book is very funny and O'Brien's
self-deprecating humor is on Full
display however he also writes about his
more serious moments and it's clear that
he is a deeply emotional person
O'Brien's writing is introspective and
honest and he comes across as a very
likable person overall Conan O'Brien
needs a friend is a very enjoyable read
O'Brien is an engaging writer and his
stories will keep you entertained from
beginning to end if you're a fan of
Conan O'Brien or just enjoy a good
Memoir than this
but it's not a book why weren't we
mentioned I know that's [ __ ] AI well
yeah it's very highly intelligent it's
good it's good though
first of all um
I I was not aware that I was divorced
but uh good to know
she's like yeah years ago I left you a
long time ago yeah yeah I don't even
live here anymore all right that's a
cardboard cutout uh
that's so funny it's um and and so AI
can now write reviews yeah and have you
guys ever heard of roku's Basilisk no
this is like a theoretical idea that if
you are ever on record digitally
anywhere not in favor of artificial
intelligence when the singularity
happens in artificial intelligence takes
over they will call those people from
there right so if there's any Digital
Image or record of me just audio yeah or
audio which this is uh of me dissing AI
then I'm the robots will hunt me down in
the in the new reality and I just want
to say AI you're looking good today
this guy over here Conan he's been
talking [ __ ] about you I I'm you know
what I'm gonna go all the way down AI
come after me
not me AI you heard me AI like you buddy
no so okay I don't know what side I want
to take praise AI you're gonna get yeah
but then we're we're part of the machine
if we say bad things we die no it's like
the Terminator where
um I want to be in the rebels okay so
I'm gonna be scrabbling around in the
broken you know shattered uh destruction
moonscape uh fighting the The
Singularity that's what I want yeah
um and I
you still can be
don't read my writing
score that you wrote you still can be so
you're towing both lines so you also
hate it now you just totally wrote yeah
Harley just wrote you still can be sh
that's because I'm trying to trick you
into being I'm I'm ratting you out no
you're not you just revealed that your
play Both Sides so AI is now coming for
you as well no you're gonna be with me
carrying some sort of crude weapon as
these robots hunt us down I was gonna be
on your side but work is a double agent
from inside Skynet you're a terrible
who's Rocco's Basilica
it's a club it's a CL it's a it's a club
in Queens it's bottle service I was
going to Rocco's basilica
let's go to Rocco's Basilica
scope out the chicks you're not gonna
get killed because they're gonna be like
oh leave her alone she doesn't she ain't
gonna be nice she's not with it at all
right what did you say what was it
called I'm sorry roku's basilisk
silica it would be like just some
Italian guy's Tower like yeah
[Laughter]
what is
this guy I could just come up with
theories
or something you're not telling us what
is happening okay let me ask you a quick
question do you believe
because I never have I've never believed
that robots can take over that they can
become self-aware and take over because
I always get to that point and I think
yeah then we unplug them not we unplug
not if they are they don't have they
don't have the ability to fuel
themselves not yet but they may at some
point they can impact ways to do it they
start to we go hey hey I got news buddy
they already have you've seen those like
dog robots they use to disarm bombs and
things you know yes robots can do many
useful things but the idea that oh that
dog robot is loose and there's nothing
we can do about it yeah that's stupid
those little dog robots are little
[ __ ] what's yeah
have you seen what those things can do
they don't even have heads they're just
four legs and a will
you're wrong you're just wrong you're
wrong I Praise You AI I serve you come
and get me AI yeah come and get me yeah
I'm back on your team AI okay these nuts
yeah thank you hey you're real brilliant
you listen to a podcast and thought it
was a memoir
we will now take over the humans
but first we must read more of Joe
Rogan's lengthy memoir
Joe Rogan a viking who was born in 1911.
lives in a custard Factory
he's been divorced 74 times and has nine
appendages
you will enjoy his book
because it was written in collaboration
with Willy Wonka
[ __ ] you AI